[Music]  ever had a dream that felt so real  he thought you were awake I like seeing  patterns and everyday routines a lot of  metal near today people for me it's a  game to find order in the chaos  [Music]  fill it what you didn't hold her  punch it the other day at work something  happened  that was my fight I nearly killed nine  hundred people nah  you saved me I know we only just met but  doesn't it feel like we've known each  other forever can't stop smiling from  ear to ear how's it there dang rout  skull sound ridiculous I keep seeing the  same people it's all part of some kind  of banner what's really going on things  are happening to me they cannot possibly  be explained exactly to 2010  Oh  sister nurses pattern  everything it's all connected  your patterns don't mean anything  people are gonna die Joey  we need to end this now  [Music]  - cream  [Music]